I mean it's poetry isn't it
I could turn so new venom trailer
dropped and I wasn't gonna talk about it
I actually said flat out and social mean
here that I wasn't gonna talk about it
but then the more I thought about the
more I'm like I need to talk about this
thing because I keep oh god this film
this project okay quick recap cuz I know
I steadily gaining subscribers as I go
along so when this project was first
announced a venom movie with no
spider-man I was like that's a stupid
idea when they said it was gonna be hard
are would they horror focus I said that
is a good way to approach what is still
a stupid idea because if you go for a
body horror angle and you lean into the
stuff that you can get away with now
that you don't have to have it appeal to
kids anymore the way spider-man does
then yes that might actually have a way
to work like it was a really narrow
target that it could work first trailer
came out and it didn't look at like it
had anything to do with the venom
whatsoever
and I was like well so much for that
then the second trailer came out and I
did rip on the second trailer a little
bit but I'll be honest I as I watched it
more kind of grew on me and I was like
okay I'm not sure they like hit the
bull's eye but maybe they're grazing
they're still grazing the target and
then this new trailer came out and I'm
back to just so I think the main reason
that I feel and I wanted to talk about
this thing was I find it really
interesting how much of venom himself is
all over this trailer and I know why
that is because and this might not have
happened if it weren't for the very
first trailer which had literally no
venom nothing and then the second
trailer came out and there's only really
the one shot of him and he says the one
line
now honestly the the look is fine but
the I watched and re-watched and and you
know that we are venom the way the mouth
movie in the eyes you know kind of
articulated a little bit I kind of start
to dig it act it and for me at least I
can't speak for any was for me at least
it was like you know I'll give it a shot
because I know there's gonna be more
than just that but the internet being
the internet lots of people lots of fans
started speculating or saying as if it
was a certainty oh man he's only gonna
be in it for like five minutes I bet you
that's the last shot of a movie and I
think Sony got really worried and
panicked that people believed venom was
barely in the venom movie and so now we
have our final trailer supposedly and he
is all over it top to bottom front to
back we can't get away from this guy now
and actually what what really threw me
off is I'm actually wondering if they've
gone back and even inserted venom more
directly into the film when he wasn't
before because like there and even
before I say this I will grant it as
possible this was just the way it was
always planned to be but there are shots
specific shots that are reused from the
second trailer and this new trailer and
in those shots last time we saw him know
visualization of this of the symbiote
and now there is like an example is when
he's against the the wall like you can
now see the tendrils sort of coming off
and holding him against the wall whereas
before it was just like him against the
wall as if it was like almost an
internal force as opposed to something
physically restraining him and that I
see that and it makes me wonder were
they always gonna add those tendrils in
or did they add those tendrils in as a
response to this because if it was their
plan to always add them in like that was
stupid to put in a shot that was going
to later be revealed by I just the next
trailer to be to have been on
finished so yeah that this whole this
trailer feels incredibly reactionary
which always makes me nervous because
when studios and studio executives go
into panic mode lots of very stupid
things happen so sort of moving beyond
that some of the other things I hate
this villain and when I say the villain
I mean the the I guess he's a
pharmaceutical guy and he's got like
this stupid monologue II thing where
he's all you know the next stage in
human evolution humans are going extinct
the world is on the brink of falling I'm
like oh for God's sake like why why
can't he just be out for profit or why
can't he just be somebody obsessed with
the science you know can I do this and
not thinking about the implications of
if it's actually a good idea you know
why can't we bring it down to a more
attainable level why does it have to be
this huge you know Darwinian maniac it
was like I've been doing this for the
good of the world and all of you human
I'll shut up like it's it's really hard
to pull that off with a villain like you
got a sink time you got it you guys seem
like Thanos time and to them to have a
character to have a villain be like that
and have it actually work because my
large just comes across as really
generic and really dumb and the
performance is bad on this guy he's just
you know you know you can just look at
him like I am smarmy evil corporate
villain human decency and you know
collateral damage Paul don't care
yeah just hated him well you got a
couple little snippets of stuff that
might feasibly be interesting we see a
woman
like sort of make a blade which I'll
come back to a second because there's a
shot towards the end that it looks like
twos to simply it's fighting and I have
a suspicion I haven't checked because I
don't usually check fan reactions before
I record these I suspect a lot of people
believe that the other one is carnage I
don't or if it is it's not attached to
Cletus Kasady yet because I think he'd
be more vibrantly red for one thing and
for another for my money the one in that
symbiote is you know our stupid
corporate villain douchebag and you know
the Cletus Cletus Kasady will get
introduced and it's the symbian is the
kind of sympathies gonna bond with him
either at the very end or in the post
credits to set up the sequel so for my
money that is not current and she's
fighting and saying part of the reason I
I'm going with that is because we see
that woman sort of do that so we're
seeing we're seeing multiple people
getting symbiote powers it's not gonna
be just venom and it's not gonna be just
venom and carnage it's gonna be other
people too to some degree or another so
there's all that and then there's and
there's the dialogue I yeah there's a
reason I picked on I was watching the
trailer for the first time and he's
going on this thing like you'd be this
this armless legless thing I'm like a
little overwrought mace is like a turd
I'm like he just said like a Turk no no
way did he say that now back it up I've
got to be hearing this wrong back up
another time nope
like a turd in the wind venom has
generally not had well-written dialogue
especially when he sort of you know in
fold sim be it for me
talks about eating people's brains and
you know even if you like that it's
cheesy and it's cheesy in a way that you
can get away with in a comic book that
doesn't translate to film as well like
there's there's a lot of stuff that I'm
really glad that comic book movies have
embraced that they used to think well we
can't do that we can't have bright
vibrant costumes everything's got to be
black leather original x-men but there
are still some things that don't work as
well and having the kinds of lines that
Venom often gets written as saying being
said out loud there's Tom they're dumb
I'm sorry they are and that man that was
painful that one and hearing that the
more I'm hearing venom talk the more
there's like a disconnect like I do like
the effect on the voice but there's
something about that effect that
monstrous effect paired with the things
he's saying I'm like this doesn't this
is incongruous in a way that isn't like
dynamic and interesting just in a this
isn't gelling so and now I'm gonna say
the thing that'll do me anyways I'm
gonna see it regardless which yes I
acknowledge that makes me part of the
problem and even though I'm complaining
about it I'm pretty sure it's not gonna
work I'm still going to pay money to see
it I fully admit to being complicit and
everything that is going on but I'm
curious I do want to see if they pull it
off so the final venom trailer what did
you think about it whatever you thought
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do you know what it is patreon
is the big one but there is a bunch of
other stuff it's all down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]